ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BURNER BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible] EIGHT MEN FLORA
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMóN OWN
[inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON PEACHTREE
NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMEAU'S RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT REAVIS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
[inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WAKES [inaudible]
WORD [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT --
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA BERMAN OF
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. SIX MONTHS AGO IN
AUGUST NOW THE CORONAS FATHER
MERCED.
YOU VETERAN WHO SERVED TWENTY
SIX YEARS AS A COLUSA COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFF.
PROBABLY PAN THE BADGE ON HIS
DAUGHTER MAKING HER AN OFFICER
WITH THE DAVIS POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THIS MORNING AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK
THOUSANDS ARE EXPECTED TO JOIN
HER FAMILY.
IN MOURNING HER LOSS AT THE UC
DAVIS ACTIVITY CENTER. ONE WEEK
AGO YESTERDAY OFFICER NOW THE
CORONA AGE.
TWENTY TWO WAS GUNNED DOWN WHILE
HELPING DRIVERS SORT OUT A THREE
CAR ACCIDENT.
I FELT DEVASTATED.
IN MY HEART.
EIGHT HOW MUCH MORE SO HER
FAMILY HER FRIENDS AND HER
FELLOW OFFICERS.
I THINK WE'VE ALL QUIETLY
WONDERED AGAIN AND AGAIN.
WHY?
BUT WE KNOW THERE IS NO
EXPLANATION THAT COULD BE OF ANY
COMFORT TO THOSE WHO KNEW AND
LOVED HER.
THERE ARE MOMENTS.
WHEN I FIND MYSELF WONDERING?
IS THERE REALLY HOPE FOR
HUMANITY.
I WONDER ARE WE AS A SPECIES.
BY NATURE SO SENSELESSLY
DESTRUCTIVE IN LACKING IN
EMPATHY.
BUT IN REFLECTION I REMEMBER
AGAIN THE GOODNESS I FELT IN
PEOPLE I'VE MET AROUND THE WORLD.
I REMEMBER AGAIN THE KINDNESS OF
STRANGERS WE'VE EXPERIENCED WHEN
WE HAVE TRAVEL.
I REMEMBER AGAIN THE LOVE OF
FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
THE HAS NURTURED ME THROUGHOUT
MY LIFE.
OFFICER CORONAS A YOUNG LIFE
FULL OF HOPE AND PURPOSE.
WAS TAKEN BY MEN WHO HAD LOST
HIS SENSE OF HUMANITY.
IN THE ACTIVE SELF RIGHTEOUS
ARROGANCE KAREN ONLY ABOUT WHAT
HE WANTED TO DO.
WITHOUT REGARD FOR OTHERS HE
TOOK OFFICER CRONUS LIFE.
ALTHOUGH IN LIFE WE MAY HAVE OUR
MOMENTS OF DESPAIR.
WE MUST NEVER STOP BELIEVING IN
THE GOODNESS OF HUMANITY.
IN THE GOODNESS OF PEOPLE WHO
ESPECIALLY SERVE TO PROTECT THE
LIVES OF EACH AND EVERYONE OF US.
LET'S OPEN OUR FLOOR SESSION TO
DATE.
WHEN LEVAN GRATITUDE FOR ALL WHO
DEDICATE THEMSELVES TO MAKING
OUR WORLD A BETTER PLACE?
ESPECIALLY OFFICER NARROWLY
CORONA AND HER FAMILY.
NUMBER ONLY DOUBTS TOO WHAT
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER FRAZIER.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING.
OUR FLAG WILL OUR PLEDGE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE [inaudible]
OUR STATES OF AMERICA --
ISRAEL [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
MONDAY DECEMBER THIRD 2018% TO
THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE OUR TWO
O'CLOCK MERIDIAN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR SESSION
OF THE LEGISLATURE IS CALLED TO
ORDER BY EACH DOTSON WILSON
CHIEF COOK A MISTER.
CALDERON MOVES.
MR DIEPPE SECONDS.
OF THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM GRAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACQUI IRWIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADRIN NAZARIAN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILLIP CHEN
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL
QUIRK.
IF A PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRANK BIGELOW.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED PROMOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BLOOM.
DAVID CHIU GABRIEL AND MEDINA TO
SPEAK ON IN THE GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
SAYS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AC ARE NUMBER.
TEN BY DR WEBER THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TEN BY SOME REMEMBER WEBER AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE REVEREND
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR'S.
DOCTOR WEBER EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
TO YOU ACR.
TEN THE RESOLUTION CELEBRATING
THE LIFE AND LEGACY OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
I WANT TO THANK THOSE OF YOU WHO
ATTENDED THE PROGRAM YESTERDAY
AND HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR
FROM SOME OF OUR LEADERS.
ANDALSO TO HEAR FROM MR AL
SHARPTON REGARDING THE LIFE OF
DR KING.
AND THE COMMITMENT WE SHOULD
HAVE TO CONTINUE HIS LEGACY.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE PROUD THAT
IT WAS THE FIRST STATE TO
ACTUALLY CELEBRATE DR KING'S
BIRTHDAY.
AND IT'S BEEN ALMOST FORTY YEARS
SINCE THE RESOLUTION WAS PASSED
AND THOSE OF US IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
ARE PROUD OF THE FACT THAT IT
WAS OUR MEMBERSHIP THAT KEPT
PUSHING AND PUSHING WITH THREE
FAILED ATTEMPTS AND FINALLY A
VICTORIOUS ATTEMPT. TO GET
DOCTOR KING'S BIRTHDAY AS A
HOLIDAY.
AND SO WE'RE PROUD OF THAT FACT
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA STOOD FIRST TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS INDIVIDUAL WOULD
BE HONORED.
SO WE'RE HERE TODAY TO CELEBRATE
THE LIFE AND LEGACY OF DOCTOR
KING AND ACR.
TEN AND YOU READ THE RESOLUTION
AND YOU GET SOME OF THE UP MOST
OF YOU'VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT
DOCTOR KING.
IS BEGINNING OF HIS LIFE BEING A
MINISTER WANTED TO SIMPLY DO HIS
WORK AS A PASTOR OF A CHURCH.
BEING.
BASICALLY CONSCRIPTED INTO THE
OF THE BATTLE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
ASA RESULT OF THE WORK OF OR
THE EFFORTS OF OF THOSE IN IN
THE IN BIRMINGHAM. TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
AND SO HE LED THE LARGEST
MOVEMENT TO TO FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
THAT IMPACTED NOT ONLY THE LIFE
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
BUT ALSO IMPACTED WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR AROUND THE STATE
IN THE NATION.
THE WORLD HEARD ABOUT DOCTOR
KING AS FAR SOUTH AFRICAN.
AND REALIZE THAT HISMOVEMENT
WAS IMPORTANT AND HE GAVE THEM
STRENGTH AND PURPOSE AS A RESULT
OF THAT MOVEMENT.
WE'RE HERE TODAY ONCE AGAIN TO
CELEBRATE HIS LIFE HIS LEGACY.
AND TO REMEMBER THE BOTH THINGS
THAT CONTINUE TO PUSH US FORWARD
AS WE IN THIS VERY DIFFICULT
TIME.
DEAL WITH THE ISSUES OF RACE AND
GENDER THAT CONTINUE TO
PENETRATE THE VALUES OF THIS
NATION.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE FOR ACR.
TEN THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER
[inaudible]
MR LACKEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES THANK YOU MEMBERS.
A VERY PROUD TO STAND HERE TODAY
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
TO CELEBRATE THE LIFE OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
AND EVERYTHING HE DID TO ADVANCE.
THE CAUSE OF CIVIL RIGHTS VERY
FEW PEOPLE KNOW THIS ABOUT ME
THAT I ACTUALLY LIVED IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
WHERE I SAW?
VERY POWERFUL RATE RACISM IN
VIRGINIA FOR ALMOST A YEAR.
AND I WAS ABLE TO SEE.
HOW HURTFUL SOME PEOPLE'S
BEHAVIOR CAN ACTUALLY BE?
THE PEOPLE WHO CLAIM TO BE
PEOPLE OF FAITH.
BUT THROUGH THE USE OF PEACEFUL
PROTEST.
DOCTOR KING WAS ABLE TO ENACT.
GREAT CHANGE.
BRING ABOUT.
A FORM OF JUSTICE.
HOWEVER THROUGH ALL THE GOOD
WORK OF PROGRESS BROUGHT BROUGHT
ABOUT BY DOCTOR KING.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE WE STILL SEE.
THE UGLY HEAD OF RACISM
CONTINUED TO SHOW ITSELF.
AND THE DIVISION IT'S CAUSING IN
OUR COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO CRITICAL. TO
HONOR DOCTOR KING IN
CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE WE'RE DOING
NOW.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE THE LEGACY
OF DR MARTIN LUTHER KING TO
CREATE A COUNTRY WHERE ALL
PEOPLE ARE EQUAL.
AND ALL PEOPLE.
HOW THE LIVES --
CHARLIE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THEIR LIVES BETTER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE WAS LACKEY MISTER DAVID
CHIU [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AS CHAIR OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACR.
TEN DR KING INSPIRED GENERATIONS.
AROUND THE WORLD TO ORGANIZE A
MOVE TOWARD.
A BETTER LIFE FOR ALL INCLUDING
MANY LEADERS WITH AN I. P. I.
COMMUNITY.
WE'VE LEADERS LIKE DR KING THE
THANK BECAUSE HE IGNITED A FIRE
THAT INSPIRED CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS SUCH AS YURI COACH
YAMA.
IN HER FIGHT FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
AS WELL AS GRACE LEE BOGGS WHO
FAMOUSLY HELPED TO ORGANIZE DR
KING'S WALK TO FREEDOM.
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
CITIZENS LEAGUE.
AS WELL AS FORMER INTERMENT CAMP
SURVIVOR TAUGHT ENDO JOIN DR
KING IN HIS MARCH FROM SELMA TO
MONTGOMERY IN SUPPORT OF VOTING
RIGHTS.
DR KING PUBLICLY OPPOSE THE WAR
IN VIETNAM MERGING THE CIVIL
RIGHTS AND PEACE MOVEMENTS
TOGETHER.
HE WAS ASSASSINATED BEFORE
SOUTHEAST ASIAN REFUGEES ARRIVED
IN THE UNITED STATES.
BUT BUILT THE FOUNDATION FOR
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
THROUGH THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE I FIRST MOVED
TO CALIFORNIA TO WORK FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION THAT WAS
FOUNDED.
BECAUSE OF THE MOVEMENT THAT HE
BEGAN.
WHETHER ANY OF US ARE DESCENDED
FROM RURAL WORKERS WERE MIGRANT
FARM WORKERS.
WEATHER WE OF THE GRANDCHILDREN
OF SOMEONE WHO SPENT TIME IN AN
INTERMENT CAMP OR AS A SLAVE.
EVERY PERSON IN THIS ROOM OWES A
DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO DR KING FOR
DARING US TO DREAM.
FROM POWER IN US TO SPEAK.
AND WITH THAT I ASK YOU TO JOIN
ALL OF US IN VOTING I FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO HONOR THE
LIFE OF DR KING.
THANK YOU MISS CHIU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND A MEMBER
SIGH A ARE ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
ALL OF OUR ACR.
TEN I WOULD LIKE TO PERSONALLY
RACCOON EYES SO DON'T LEADERSHIP
AND THE SACRIFICE OF DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR DAY.
FOOD THIS COUNTRY.
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING.
YES THE THE CHANGE IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OFFOR THIS COUNTRY THAT
ALL MINORITY MEMBERS SO ENJOYED
TODAY.
AS AN IMMIGRANT TO THIS AMAZING
COUNTRY I TRULY APPRECIATE ALL
RIGHTS AND THE LIBERTIES SAID
THAT DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR'S TO AND THE FOR THE TO
ATTAIN.
IT IS SUB BECAUSE ALL OF OUR HIS
TO SACRIFICE SO THAT THE MANY
PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS.
CAN ENJOY GREAT OR LIBERTIES ARE
AND A BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE.
FOR FOR THEMSELVES SO AND OF THE
FAMILY IS.
SURELY MD ON ONE OF THE
BENEFICIARIES SO.
IT IS UP WITH THE OBVIOUS
THOUGHTS ON THOSE SOLEMN MEMORY
THAT I STAND IN SUPPORT OF WHAT
A. C. R..
TEND TO RECOGNIZE OF THIS A WAIT
MAN.
AND THE LEGACY HE LEFT THE FOR
THIS COUNTRY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION.
AS WE HEARD YESTERDAY AT THE
BREAKFAST AT THE BLACK CAUCUS
BREAKFAST THE FIGHT. TO HONOR DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING'S LEGACY WITH
A STATE AND NATIONAL HOLIDAY.
WAS ALMOST AS HARD AS HIS FIGHT
AGAINST PREJUDICE AND BIAS.
DOCTOR KING FOUGHT AGAINST
PREJUDICE AND BIAS.
HE SPOKE UNCOMFORTABLE TRUTHS.
ABOUT THE INJUSTICES IN THE MANY
SYSTEMS THAT DEFINE AND HARNESS
OUR COUNTRY.
IN EDUCATION IN OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
WITH HEALTHCARE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
VOTING RIGHTS.
GENDER BIAS.
THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND HOUSING.
AS MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW.
I AM THE PRODUCT OF A BIRACIAL
MARRIAGE.
AND MY PARENTS WERE DENIED THE
RIGHT TO LIVE.
IN AN APARTMENT IN CHICAGO
BECAUSE THEY WERE INTERRACIAL.
NOT LONG AFTER HIS DEATH.
WHICH GOES TO SHOW YOU THAT MANY
OF THESE FIGHTS ARE STILL ON
GOING.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT WE ARE
LIVING IN AN ERA.
A TALE OF TWO CALIFORNIA'S.
AND AT THE CENTER OF THAT TALE.
IS ANY QUALITY.
AND ON AFFORDABILITY.
SO LAST WE LET CALIFORNIA
SUCCUMB. TO THIS COMPLETELY.
I HOPE WE WILL USE THIS WEEKEND
I HOPE WE WILL USE HIS LEGACY
AND I HOPE WE WILL USE HIS
BIRTHDAY. TO STEP INTO THE
UNCOMFORTABLE CENTER OF
PREJUDICE RACISM AND BIAS.
AND WORK TOWARDS JUSTICE.
THIS HOLIDAY WEEKEND MARKS THE
ANNIVERSARY OF DR KING'S BIRTH
AND MANY OF US WILL BE
PARTICIPATING AND WOMEN'S MARCH
AS MUCH OF WHAT DOCTOR KING WORK
TO REMEDY REMAINS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY FOR WOMEN.
PARTICULARLY FOR WOMEN OF COLOR.
SO AS WE WORK TOWARDS EQUITY LET
US BE INTENTIONAL IN WHAT WE
TRULY MEAN ABOUT FIGHTING IT
[inaudible]
MS RACE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO CAUCUS.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A C. R.
TOWN.
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR WAS
AN AMERICAN CIVIL RIGHTS PIONEER
WHOSE IMPACT IS IMMEASURABLE.
HIS WORK WAS UNDOUBTEDLY
PROGRESSIVE.
AND FOCUSED ON RACIAL EQUALITY
ECONOMIC EQUALITY.
AND ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
DESPITE THE CONSTANCY AND
HARASSMENT OF CONSTANCY OF
VIOLENCE AND HARASSMENT HE
ANOTHER SPACED DR KING WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO MAINTAIN THE
MOVEMENT.
OF PEACEFUL RESISTANCE.
HIS STRENGTH AND DETERMINATION
TO FIGHT FOR SOMETHING HE SO
STRONGLY BELIEVED IN REGARDLESS
OF THIS THREATS ON HIS LIFE.
SHOWS A REMARKABLE EXTRAORDINARY
PERSON HE WAS.
DR KING OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT TO HELP CHANGE PUBLIC
POLICY FOR ALL PEOPLE OF COLOR.
LEADING TO THE PASSAGE OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT
OF NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AND OTHER
LAWS INTENDED TO TERMINATE.
LEGAL AND ECONOMIC BARRIERS IN
AMERICA.
DR KING'S MESSAGES YOU APPEAR TO
ME OF HOPE FREEDOM AND
PERSEVERANCE.
ALTHOUGH WE'VE COME A LONG WAY
WE STILL HAVE MUCH TO DO.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE WE HAVE AN
AMERICA THE DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR AND HIS COMPLETE
CONTEMPORARIES WOULD BE PROUD TO
LIVE IN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ADDRESS MR GABRIEL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS. TO HONOR THE REMARKABLE
LIFE AND LEGACY OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
THE JEWISH CAUCUS IS PROUD TO
STAND WITH SO MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN RECOGNIZING DR
KING.
AS ONE OF THE GREATEST AMERICANS
OF ANY GENERATION.
DR KING IS ALWAYS OCCUPIED A
SPECIAL PLACE IN THE HEARTS AND
MINDS OF AMERICAN JEWS. FOR MANY
IN OUR COMMUNITY DOCTOR KING WAS
THE LIVING EMBODIMENT OF THE
QUEST FOR FREEDOM HUMAN DIGNITY
AND JUSTICE BUT ARE THE CENTRAL
FOCUS OF JEWISH TRADITION.
INDEED FEW IMAGES INSPIRE AS
MUCH EMOTION AND PRIDE IN THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY AS THE ICONIC
IMAGE OF DOCTOR OF RIVER OF
RABBI ABRAHAM JOSHUA HESCHEL.
THE MOST REVERED RABBIS OF HIS
GENERATION MARCHING ARM IN ARM
WITH DOCTOR KING ACROSS THE
EDMUND PETTUS BRIDGE IN MARCH OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE AFTERWARDS
IN WORDS THAT WERE QUOTED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA HALF A CENTURY
LATER.
RABBI HESCHEL REFLECTED THAT
WHEN HE WAS MARCHING WITH DOCTOR
KING HE FELT THAT HIS LEGS WERE
PRAYING.
THAT SAME YEAR THE AMERICAN
JEWISH COMMITTEE ON OR DOCTOR
KING WITH ITS FIRST YOU JUST
AMERICAN LIBERTIES MEDALLION.
IN RECOGNITION OF HIS EFFORTS TO
ADVANCE CIVIL RIGHTS AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE FOR ALL AMERICANS.
DOCTOR KING WAS ALSO GREAT
FRIEND AND ALLY TO THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY IN OUR OWN STRUGGLES.
HE SPOKE OUT POWERFULLY AGAINST
ANTI SEMITISM IN DEFENSE OF THE
STATE OF ISRAEL.
AND IT ENDED AND ON BEHALF OF
HUMAN RIGHTS FOR PERSECUTED JEWS
IN THE SOVIET UNION.
THE GLOBAL JEWISH COMMUNITIES
TREMENDOUS AFFECTION FOR DR KING
IS PERHAPS BEST EVIDENT IN
JERUSALEM.
WHERE EACH DAY THOUSANDS WALKED
DOWN A BOULEVARD RENAMED IN HIS
HONOR?
IN THE HEART OF THE CITY WHERE
THE STREETS ARE NAMED FOR THE
GREAT KINGS AND PROFITS OF
ANCIENT ISRAEL.
THE JEWISH PEOPLE CHOSE TO OUT
OF THOROUGHFARE NAME FOR
AMERICA'S GREAT PROFIT OF
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THIS WEEKEND JEWISH COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WILL HOLD
SPECIAL SERVICES TO HONOR DOCTOR
KING.
WE WILL TEACH OUR CHILDREN ABOUT
HIS ENORMOUS BRAVERY HIS MORAL
CLARITY AND HIS ON FINISH
STRUGGLE FOR JUSTICE.
WE WERE REFLECT ON HIS
TREMENDOUS ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
YET ALSO CRINGE AT HOW MUCH WORK
REMAINS TO TRULY FULFILL HIS
DREAM.
AND WE WILL SEEK TO HONOR HIS
LEGACY BY JOINING HANDS WITH
OTHER COMMUNITIES TO ADVANCE
JUSTICE AND HELP FULFILL HIS
VISION.
IN THAT SPIRIT AND ON BEHALF OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
THERE WAS A REAL MISSED COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I AM VERY PLEASED TO
RISE TODAY IN HONOR OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING.
AND ON THIS DAY I'M ALWAYS.
PRONE TO THINK OF HIM.
AND THINK OF MY GRANDDAUGHTER
AND A COOLEY --
WHO IS OF AFRO AMERICAN HERITAGE?
BECAUSE OF COURSE THE WORK OF DR
KING CHANGE THE WORLD FOR HER.
SHE'S NOW STARTING SCHOOL HERE
IN RANCHO CORDOVA [inaudible]
AND ON THIS DAY AS I REFLECT
UPON DOCTOR KING AND JUSTICE.
MINISTER OF THE GOSPEL.
COMMITTED TO JUST GIVING
EXPRESSION TO WHAT HE HAD
CONVICTIONS ON THE IMPACT OF HIS
LIFE.
THE TRANSFORMATIVE WAY IN WHICH
HE TOUCHED OTHER'S.
AND INFLUENCES INFLUENCE THEM.
IN MULTIPLE WAYS.
HE INFLUENCE SOME PEOPLE. TO
JOIN THE FIGHT. TO BUCK THEM UP.
TO PERSEVERE IN THE FACE OF
CHALLENGE.
HE ENCOURAGE OTHERS PEOPLE
[inaudible] TO FEEL
[inaudible]
HEARTENED. TO FEEL REMEMBERED.
TO FEEL VALUED.
AND THEN OF COURSE IN YET
ANOTHER WAY HE HE I THANK.
POLL THE SCREEN AWAY MADE IT
EASIER TO TO SAY WELL.
I I JUST HEARD SOMETHING EXPRESS
WHICH IS WRONG.
WHICH IS NOT RIGHT.
WHICH I DO NOT AGREE WITH.
WHICH MAY BE A CONVENTIONAL
ATTITUDE WAS NOT A RIGHT
ATTITUDE.
SO PEOPLE EMBOLDENED PEOPLE HE
HARDENED AND PEOPLE YOU SORT OF
SAID.
WHAT'S GOING ON AND WITH ALL OF
THIS IT BECAUSE WE REFLECT UPON.
AS HE WAS IN A MINISTER.
THE BOOK OF ISAIAH.
AND PERMISSION TO READ BRIEFLY
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THIS IS THE I'D SAY A THIRTY TWO
AND I'LL POINT OUT TO YOU THAT
THE THIRD WORD AND WHAT'S GOING
TO COME OUT OF MY MOUTH
[inaudible]
IS KING.
SEE A KING.
WILL REIGN IN RIGHTEOUSNESS.
AND RULERS WILL RULE WITH
JUSTICE.
SURE AND THAT WAS WHAT HE KEPT
HIS EYE UPON [inaudible]
THE KING.
BUT JUSTICE AND RIGHTEOUSNESS.
IN THE WAY OUR SOCIETY WAS RULED
[inaudible]
EACH.
ONE WILL BE LIKE A SHELTER FROM
THE WIND.
IN A REFUGE FROM THE STORM.
SO NOW WE HAVE WHERE SOMEONE
ACTS WITH JUSTICE AND
RIGHTEOUSNESS.
THEY ARE CREATING SAFE SPACES
FOR PEOPLE.
ISN'T THIS WHAT HE HAS DONE.
LIKE STREAMS OF WATER IN THE
DESERT AND THE SHADOW OF A GREAT
ROCK IN A THIRSTY LAND.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING IMAGE
ISAIAH.
SHOT OF A GREAT ROCK AND WERE
LAND THAT ACTUALLY MEANS.
A BIG ROCK OF THE LANDSCAPE.
THAT THE SUN POUNDS UPON.
THEREBY CREATING SAFE SPACES.
NO THAT'S SAVE QUITE A VIVID
IMAGE OF LEADERSHIP.
AND IT'S MOST TRAGIC DAY.
IT'S AN IMAGE OF HIS LEADERSHIP.
THAT BY HIS LIFE.
HE WAS OUT THERE IN THE BEATING
SON.
CRITICS A SPACES FOR PEOPLE.
AND AND BEARING THAT COST.
THEN THE EYES OF THOSE WHO SEE
SAYS AYES THERE WILL NO LONGER
BE CLOSED.
AND THE EARS OF THOSE WHO HEAR
WILL LISTEN.
THIS WORK OF LEADERSHIP CHANGE
THE WAY PEOPLE PERCEIVE THE
WORLD AROUND THEM.
OPEN OUR EYES OPEN ERRORS.
THE FEARFUL HEART WILL NO ONE
UNDERSTANDS.
AND THE STAMMERING TONGUE WILL
BE FLUENT IN CLEAR.
TOUCHING LIVES OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE BE SEVEN THIS
MAY.
AND AGAIN BECAUSE OF THIS KING
IN THE WAY HE CONDUCTS HIMSELF
AND MARTIN LUTHER KING.
NO LONGER WILL THE FOOL BE
CALLED NOBLE.
NO THE SCOUNDREL BE HIGHLY
RESPECTED.
SO I THINK THIS IS A GREAT DATE
REMEMBER THE PROFOUND WORK OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
HIS LEADERSHIP.
HIS COMMITMENT TO KINGDOM VALUES
AS HE UNDERSTOOD THEM.
THE INSPIRATION AS BRENDA
GENERATIONS OF LEADERS.
THE SOURCE OF HOPE TO PEOPLE WHO
OTHERWISE FELT AT RISK.
AND GIVEN US ALL THE ABILITY THE
KIND OF SAY.
TIMES UP.
THE VOICE I'M HEARING IS NOT A
VOICE THAT I AGREE WITH.
IT'S ACTUALLY VOICE OF POLLY
[inaudible]
AND CERTAINLY IN OUR DAY IN OUR
SOCIETY WE NEED PEOPLE STAND UP.
AND SAY THAT.
SO IT'S AN HONOR STAND HERE IN
HONOR OF THIS DAY THANK YOU.
NAME IS COOLEY MISTER GLORIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY -- LGBT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN STRONG
SUPPORTER ACR TEN WITH
APPRECIATION TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO.
IT IS A MATTER OF SOME.
DEBATE WITHIN THE LGBT COMMUNITY
WHERE KING STOOD WHEN IT CAME TO
OUR ISSUES.
I MYSELF HAVE NO DEBATE ON THE
MATTER IT IS CLEAR THE KING
STOOD ON THE SIDE OF LGBT A
QUALITY.
YOU CAN SEE IT ALL AROUND MAYBE
NOT IN HIS WORDS ARE HIS
SPECIFIC ACTIONS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO LGBT COMMUNITY WE
KNOW WITHIN HIS MOVEMENT.
OUR COMMUNITY WAS ALWAYS
REPRESENTED.
THE MARCH IN NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED
WITHOUT THE GENIUS ABED RUSTED.
A MEMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY WHO
WAS OUT IN A TIME WHEN IT WAS SO
DIFFICULT TO DO EMBRACED BY DR
KING IS A PART OF HIS LEADERSHIP
CIRCLE.
HIS WIFE HIS WIDOW CORETTA SCOTT
KING WAS A PASSIONATE ELOQUENT
STRONG VOICE FOR OUR COMMUNITY
AGAIN WHEN IT WAS NOT
NECESSARILY POPULAR. TO DO THAT
SHE REMAINS AN ICON FOR EQUALITY
FOR LGBT AMERICANS.
AND SO WHETHER IT'S HIS WIFE FOR
HIS INNER CIRCLE CLEARLY KING
WAS INFLUENCED BY THE PEOPLE
AROUND HIM WHO KNEW THAT
EQUALITY MET NOT JUST RACIAL
JUSTICE.
BUT JUSTICE FOR THOSE IN THE WAY
OF NOW.
THE TENETS OF OUR MOVEMENT OF
LGBT EQUAL RIGHTS MOVEMENT ARE
COMPLETELY CONNECTED. TO THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT THE
BROADER CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
CONCEPTS LIKE WE SHOULD BE
JUDGED BY THE CONTENT OF OUR
CHARACTER.
THAT IS EQUAL TO US THAT IS A
PILLAR OF OUR MOVEMENT.
THE IDEA THE INJUSTICE ANYWHERE
IS A THREAT TO JUSTICE
EVERYWHERE IS A PART OF OUR
MOVEMENT.
AND OF COURSE THE IDEA THAT
SEPARATE IS NOT EQUAL IS VERY
MUCH A PART OF OUR MOVEMENT.
AND SO WHEN DOCTOR KING WAS
OUTSPOKEN.
ABOUT MARRIAGE EQUALITY WHEN IT
CAME TO OF RACIAL INTEGRATION.
BUT WE KNOW HE WAS ALSO TALKING.
ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO HAVE
MARRIAGE EQUALITY.
AND I WOULD LINK UP THE ABILITY
IN THE FACT THAT OUR MOVEMENTS
ARE INTER TWINED BY THE FACT
THAT WE TODAY ENJOY THE ABILITY
TO SERVE OPENLY IN THE MILITARY.
AND THE ABILITY TO GET MARRIED
IN THIS NATION BECAUSE THE FIRST
BLACK PRESIDENT UNITED STATES
HELP CHAMPION THOSE ISSUES.
SO I STAND A ON BEHALF OF A
CAUCUS EIGHT STRONG AND A DEEP
APPRECIATION TO OUR COLLEAGUES
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS.
OUR ISSUES ARE LEADS WE ARE
INTERSECTIONAL OUR SUCCESS IS
NOT EXCLUSIVE IT IS MUTUAL AND
WE ARE DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE FOR
THE IMPACT THE DOCTOR KING HAS
MADE.
IN RACIAL JUSTICE BUT ALSO FOR
LGBT EQUALITY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA MISTER
GIBSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY ONE OF MY
FAVORITE DOCTOR MARTHA KING --
FOR YOUR HEARING.
LIFE BEGINS THE IN THE MOMENT
YOU START BEING SILENT ABOUT THE
THINGS THAT MATTER.
IN THE END WE WERE NOT REMEMBER
THE WORDS OF OUR ENEMIES BUT THE
A SILENCE.
OF OUR FRIENDS.
WE WILL HAVE TO REPENT IN THIS
GENERATION NOT MERELY FOR THEIR
VITRIOLIC WORDS AND ACTION OF
THE BAD PEOPLE.
BUT THE APPALLING SILENCE OF THE
GOOD PEOPLE THERE COMES A TIME
THAT SILENCE IS A FORM OF
BETRAYAL.
DAVIS GIPSON ALL DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION HAVING SEIZE.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE VARIOUS
CAUCUSES WHO'VE TAKEN THE TIME
TO RESPOND TO THIS RESOLUTION.
AND TO GIVE US QUOTES AND AND
ASPECTS OF DR KING'S LIFE WHICH
WAS AN AMAZING LIFE.
THAT RESULTED IN A VERY EARLY AN
UNFORTUNATE DEATH.
IT BECAME CLEAR TO ME SOME LAST
YEAR AS I LISTEN TO MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF DR KING'S
ASSASSINATION.
THAT MOST OF YOU DID NOT LIVE
DURING THE TIME OF KING.
THERE WERE FEW OF US WHO DID IT
AND I WAS ONE OF THOSE.
AND SO MOST OF YOUR KNOWLEDGE
AND FEELINGS ABOUT KING A REALLY
FROM A BOOK.
FROM THE MOVIE FROM SOME STORIES
OF PEOPLE TOLD YOU.
AS I POINTED OUT YESTERDAY I WAS
A STUDENT UCLA.
WHEN WE GOT THE WORD THE DOCTOR
KING HAD BEEN KILLED?
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE THAT A MAN
OF PEACE.
COULD BE TAKEN AWAY IN SUCH A
VIOLENT ACT.
AND A LEFT US ALL WONDERING
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY.
WE ALSO BETRAYED.
WE OUGHT WE ALL FELT THAT
SOMEHOW ANOTHER.
ALL OF THE GOOD THAT THIS MAN
HAD DONE.
WAS TO EXPOSE THE HATRED.
OF OF THOSE WHO ARE IRRATIONAL.
TO TAKE HIS LIFE.
AND WE WONDERED IF THE DREAM
WOULD DIE WOULD DOCTOR KING.
WAS THERE NOT PLANTED IN
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS NATION TO
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR WHAT WAS
RIGHT AND WHAT WAS JUST.
AND THOSE WHO WERE MOST
FRUSTRATED TOOK THE STREETS AND
BURN THE CITIES.%
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO ANGRY ABOUT
THE FACT THAT DOCTOR KING WAS
DEAD.
THAT THE KING WAS THE IT.
THE DREAM WOULD NOT GO FORWARD.
AND THAT ALL OF THE FIVE THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
WOULD BE MESSED.
MOST OF US KNOW ABOUT THE SOUTH.
AB MY FAMILY HAD COME FROM THE
SOUTH AND I VISITED THE SOUTH
MANY TIMES AS A CHILD.
AND WE DO OF THE UGLINESS OF
RACISM AND DISCRIMINATION.
WE KNEW HOW IT MADE PEOPLE FEEL.
MOST OF US THAT HAVE RELATIVES
MY GRANDFATHER NEVER HAD THE
CHANCE TO VOTE IN THIS NATION.
WAS A CITIZEN OF THIS NATION
BORN IN THIS COUNTRY BUT NEVER
HAD THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN HOPE
ARKANSAS.
AND SO WE UNDERSTOOD WHAT IT WAS
TO TALK ABOUT JIM CROW IN A VERY
REAL SENSE.
AND I KNEW WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO
TRAVEL TO THE SOUTH AND NOT BE
ABLE TO GO TO THE RESTROOM.
THURGOOD MARSHALL TALKED ABOUT
THAT IT IS NOT JUST AN
INCONVENIENCE RACISM IT IS IT
TAKES AWAY YOUR DIGNITY AND YOUR
PRIDE AS A RESULT OF NOT BEING
ABLE TO DO JUST THE SIMPLE
THINGS OF LIFE.
AND SO DR KING'S LIFE
REPRESENTED ALL OF THAT TO US.
AND SO HERE WE STOOD AT UCLA AND
AROUND THE NATION YOUNG PEOPLE.
WONDERING WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
WE'RE BEING TOLD BY ALL OF THE
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ORGANIZATION
THE PAMPA ORGANIZATION AND
OTHERS.
THAT NONVIOLENCE DID NOT WORK.
BUT ALL IT DID WAS PRODUCE
VIOLENCE IN KING'S LIFE WAS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT.
AND SO WE HAD SOME ISSUES AND
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER NOT THIS
COUNTRY WOULD CONTINUE THE
LEGACY TO CONTINUE THE WORK.
THAT HAD NOT BEEN FINISHED.
WE STILL HAVE A QUESTION TODAY.
IT HAS NOT GONE AWAY.
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE IN THIS
COUNTRY IS AFRICAN AMERICANS
CONTINUE. TO BE CHALLENGES WE
FACE EACH AND EVERY DAY.
AND WE WILL KNOW THAT AT THE
TIME OF KING'S DEATH BUT HE WAS
NOT A POPULAR PERSON.
HE'S VERY POPULAR TODAY BECAUSE
HE'S NOT A LOT.
YES HE'S NOT CONTINUE TO
CHALLENGE US DIRECTLY.
BUT HE WAS NOT POPULAR WHEN HE
DIED.
WE KNEW THAT HE WAS HE HAD LOW
APPROVAL RATINGS IN MANY
COMMUNITIES.
HE WAS SEEN AS THE ENEMY THE F.
B. I.'S SAW HIM AS THE ENEMY AND
THE AND THE WORST THING --
TO FOR DEMOCRACY IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND SO HE LIVED THE LIFE THAT
WAS DIFFICULT.
HE CAME TO SAN DIEGO AND NONE OF
THE BLACK MINISTERS WILL LET HIM
SPEAK AT THE CHURCHES IN THE
SIXTIES.
BECAUSE THEY WERE AFRAID OF
BEING SEEN WITH THIS RADICAL.
AND SO HE INSTEAD HE SPOKE IN
THE GYMNASIUM AT SAN DIEGO STATE.
AND THAT BECAME THE PRIDE OF SAN
DIEGO STATE THAT THEY OPEN THEIR
DOORS TO MARTIN LUTHER KING.
BUT THE BLACK COMMUNITY IN THE
MINISTER'S WOULD NOT LET HIM
SPEAK FOR FEAR OF WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO THEM.
AND THEY'D BE IDENTIFIED WITH
HIS RADICAL INDIVIDUALS IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN SIXTIES.
SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT KING.
IF WE WANT TO BE LIKE KING.
YOU HAVE TO REALIZE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE UNPOPULAR TIMES.
BECAUSE YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
RIGHT AND WHAT IS JUST.
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS A POPULARITY
CONTEST WE SEE THAT EVERY DAY.
WHAT WE HAVE THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY IN A UNIQUE CHANCE
TO BE THE DOCTOR KING OF OUR
GENERATION? TO DEAL WITH THE
DIFFICULT ISSUES THEN THE HARD
ISSUES.
AND TRY TO BRING SOME JUSTICE
AND EQUALITY TO SO MANY.
WE OFTEN STAND ON THIS FLOOR
WITH DIFFICULT BILLS DEAL WITH
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES.
AND I HAVE TO REMIND MYSELF THAT
THIS COUNTRY JUST LAST YEAR MAY
LYNCHING ILLEGAL IN THIS COUNTRY.
UNBELIEVABLE AFTER YEARS AND
YEARS OF TORTURE AND LYNCHING WE
FINALLY PASSED ABOUT A BILL IN
WASHINGTON TO MAKE LYNCHING
ILLEGAL.
THAT IS A FORM OF TERRORISM THAT
CONTINUES TO EXIST.
WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE OTHER FORMS
OF KILLING ILLEGAL IN THIS
COUNTRY.
OUR SPEAKER YESTERDAY TALK ABOUT
STEFAN CLARK.
WHICH CONTINUES THE LEGACY OF
DIFFICULT RELATIONSHIPS WITH
POLICE OFFICERS ARE PEOPLE OF
AUTHORITY IN AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND LATINO COMMUNITIES.
THOSE ARE NOT EASY ISSUES THERE
DIFFICULT ISSUES.
BUT WE STAND WITH KING WE HAVE
TO REALIZE THAT BASICALLY
DEALING WITH THOSE ISSUES WILL
BE ISSUES THAT WE WILL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IN A STRONG WAY THAT
MAY NOT MAKE US POPULAR.
BUT IN THE END WILL GIVE US A
LEGACY OF JUSTICE AND EQUALITY.
I'VE OFTEN SAID ON THIS FLOOR AS
I CLOSE [inaudible]
THAT FREEDOM.
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE.
IS A RARE FLOWER.
THE DEMANDS CONSTANT ATTENTION
AND WATERING AND LOVE AND CARE.
BUT WE KNOW THAT HATRED IS A
WHEAT.
AND IT GROWS BEST IN NYC LACKED.
AND IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT THE
BEAUTY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE GREATNESS OF THIS NATION.
IT WILL DEMAND FROM US CONSTANT
ATTENTION TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
WEEDS OF HATE DO NOT GROW AND
FASTER IN AMERICA.
MISTER SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. FOR A C.
R. TEN AND THAT THE FOR ALL WILL
BE OPEN FIRST ROLL CALL AUTHORS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER DOCTOR
WEBER IS REQUESTING THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION CARP WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE SEVEN EIGHT ONE
CO AUTHORS AT ON THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS. TWO AND THREE PASS
AND RETAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR THIS IS AJ ARE.
ONE BY MISTER DALY OF CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO VIETNAMESE REFUGEES.
MISTER DAILY EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. TEN
YEARS AGO THE UNITED STATES.
AND THE COUNTRY OF VIETNAM
AGREED TO PROHIBIT THE
DEPORTATION OF VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS WHO ARRIVED IN THE US
AS REFUGEES PRIOR TO JULY.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY CALLS ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO STOP ANY
EFFORT TO CHANGE THAT AGREEMENT.
WHICH COULD DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS DEPORTED
BACK TO VIETNAM.
DEPORTATIONS A VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS.
WOULD NOT ONLY UNDERMINE THE
SPIRIT OF THAT AGREEMENT.
BUT WILL ALSO TEAR APART
FAMILIES WHO HAVE FOR MANY
DECADES CALL THE U. S. THEIR
HOME.
IN SUPPORTING THIS RESOLUTION
TODAY.
WE WILL DEMONSTRATE THE
CALIFORNIA STANDS IN SOLIDARITY
WITH OUR VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
RESIDENTS.
THOUSANDS OF ROOM FOUGHT ON OUR
SIDE DURING THE VIETNAM WAR
BEFORE FLEEING COMMUNISM IN
SEARCH OF FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
THE DALY MISTER DE UP.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY AS A PROWL.
PRINTABLE CO AUTHOR OF ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION.
ONE I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ANAHEIM FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
FOR SPEAKER IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH
SIGNED THIS AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE UNITED STATES AND VIETNAM.
TO PROTECT.
MEETING THESE IMMIGRANTS WHO
ARRIVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
PRIOR TO JULY TWELVE NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE FROM DEPORTATION.
YOU MAYES IMMIGRANTS HAVE FLED
THE COUNTRY THAT IMPOSED
RESTRICTION ON FREEDOM OF SPEECH
FREEDOM OF PRESS.
FREEDOM OF ASSEMBLY AND FREEDOM
OF ASSOCIATION.
AS AN IMMIGRANT MYSELF.
BEING ABLE TO BE ON THIS FLOOR
AND ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF MY
COMMUNITY.
IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW FAR.
WE HAVE COME.
YOU CAN FIND MANY LITTLE
CYCLONES COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
IN SAN DIEGO.
ORANGE COUNTY.
SACRAMENTO [inaudible]
SAN JOSE.
WE ARE A STATE AND COUNTRY OF
GIVING PEOPLE.
A SECOND OPPORTUNITY.
BE TO ME IS IMMIGRANTS WERE
GIVEN A SECOND CHANCE TO REBUILD
THEIR LIVES.
WE SHOULD GIVE EVERYONE A SECOND
CHANCE ESPECIALLY TO THOSE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE PAID THEIR DEBT.
TO SOCIETY AND ARE NOW
CONTRIBUTING TO THIS GREAT STATE
AND NATION.
SO I STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH MY
COMMUNITY.
IN RESPECTFULLY ASKING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO HONOR.
THAT AGREEMENT THAT WAS SIGNED
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DEEP.
THIS CALL ROUTE YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
WANNA THANK --
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ANAHEIM FOR
BRING THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION
FOR THEM --
HONORED TO BE A JOINT AUTHORED
AND STAND ALSO --
ON BEHALF A. P. I. CAUCUS --
YOU KNOW ATTACKS ON IMMIGRANTS
AND REFUGEE FAMILIES OR OR NOT
NEW AND IN FACT WE'VE SEEN.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED VIETNAMESE.
BOAT INDIVIDUALS OF ALREADY BEEN
DEPORTED BACK TO COUNTRIES THAT
THEY HARDLY KNOW OR IN SOME
CASES DON'T KNOW AT ALL.
NOW THE FEDERAL MINISTRATION IS
EXPANDING THEIR EFFORTS --
SEEKING TO DEPORT VIETNAMESE
PEOPLE WHO RIDE TO THE UNITED
STATES BEFORE JULY NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE JUST REGARDING.
AN AGREEMENT --
WITH VIETNAM THAT WOULD OUR TIME
REFUGEES FROM DEPORTATION --
AS WE'VE HEARD FROM --
OF OUR COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA IS
HOME. TO THE COUNTRY'S LARGEST
SOUTHEAST ASIAN AND SPECIFICALLY
VIETNAMESE POPULATION IN FACT
SAN JOSE HAS THE LARGEST BIT
MEANS POPULATION ANY SINGLE CITY
OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM.
MANY OF THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WOULD BE DEPORTED TO COUNTRIES
THEY FLED.
AS INTENSE AND AS CHILDREN.
AND IT CERTAINLY COOL TO TURN
OUR BACKS ON REFUGEES WHO DON'T
KNOW ANY OTHER HOME THEN THE
UNITED STATES --
AND WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE IT'S
NOT DISSIMILAR TO THE ISSUES
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE CENTRAL AMERICAN
REFUGEES WHO ARE SEEKING ASYLUM.
AND SOME MAY THINK WELL THIS WAS
DECADES AGO THAT'S IN THE PAST.
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY FAR FROM
HISTORY BECAUSE THE REALITY IS
THAT AS SOON AS MANY OF THESE
REFUGEES CAME TO OUR SHORES AND
MADE AMERICA THEIR HOME THEY
STARTED EXERCISING THE RIGHTS
THAT THEY HAVE IN THIS NATION.
OF FREEDOM THE RIGHTS TO FREEDOM
OF SPEECH THEY'VE SPOKEN UP
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT AND
VIETNAM NOT JUST TWENTY THIRTY
OR FORTY YEARS AGO BUT TO THIS
DAY.
AND WE KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
VIETNAM RIGHT NOW THEIR JAILING
PEOPLE THEY'RE BEATING PEOPLE
THEY'RE KILLING PEOPLE THAT ARE
SPEAKING UP.
THE SPEEDING UP TO STAND UP FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS TO STAND AGAINST
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION.
IN THEIR NATION AND TO STAND UP
AGAINST AGGRESSION FROM THEIR
NEIGHBORS.
AND SO THIS IS A VERY REAL
THREAT IT'S NOT EXISTENTIALISTS.
IF INDIVIDUALS ARE DEPORTED BACK.
TO BE AT NAM THEY VERY VERY
LIKELY WILL BE IMPRISONED.
JAILED FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME
THEY COULD BE PHYSICALLY HARMED.
AND CERTAINLY THERE LIFE CAN BE
THREATENED SO THIS IS NOT --
AN ISSUE BUT WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT SOME ARE TRYING TO PROTECT
OF FOLKS WHO NOW CALL AMERICA
HOME WHICH THEY DO AND THAT BY
ITSELF WOULD BE VALID AND OF
VALUE.
HOWEVER THIS IS A REAL THREAT
AND LIVES ARE BEING PLAYED WITH
IN A WAY --
THAT IS DANGEROUS AND WE
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD NOT BE.
MANIPULATING OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM OR AGREEMENTS WE HAVE
WITH OTHER NATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN PLACE TO PROTECT
AMERICANS PROTECT PEOPLE AND
PROTECT THOSE WHO CALL THIS
NATION HOME.
AND SO I URGE OUR COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT AG ARE ONE AND AGAIN I'M
GRATEFUL TO OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
ANAHEIM FOR BRING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
CHECK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAM I'M
MEMBERS AYE RICE ON BEHALF OF
ALL THE MANY API CAUCUS MEMBERS.
IN SUPPORT OF EACH YEAR ARE ONE
AND IN SUPPORT OF THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY.
THERE'S A LARGE NUMBER OF
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES ESTABLISH
DEEP ROOT IN MY DISTRICT.
AND DEAR THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF VERY APPARENT.
THOSE PEOPLE HAVE GONE THROUGH
TRAUMA.
AND HARDSHIP TO FIND FREEDOM.
AND A BETTER LIFE FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
DISH AND NOT HAVE TO LIVE IN
FEAR OF BEING DEPORTED. TWO A
COUNTRY THAT THE WORD FORCE TO
OF FLEE FROM.
IT'S A SIMPLE.
THERE IS A AGREEMENT IN PLACE.
AND THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
REASON TO CONSIDER CHANGING THAT.
I'M GLAD THAT WE COMMITTED TO
STAND BEHIND THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY AND AGAINST POLICIES
THAT MAKE PEOPLE FILL THEM --
WELL CALM AND FEAR.
FOR ON BEHALF OF MY CONSTITUENTS
FROM ANAHEIM AND MANY AUG A
SIMPLICITY AND MANY OTHER PLACES
FOR BRINGING THIS A RESOLUTION.
FOR IT IS THE RIGHT THING FOR US
TO DO AND I URGE FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANKS YOU MISTER VOEPEL.
YOUR RECOGNIZED MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I SPEAK IS A OF
VIETNAM VETERAN AND I AGREE.
COMPLETELY.
WITH SUPPORT IN A J. ARE.
ONE AND I POINT OUT I HAVE THE
TREATY OF MY HAND.
IT'S A SIMPLE TREATY STRAIGHT
FORWARD.
CAN BE CANCELLED IN THIRTY DAYS
BY EITHER GOVERNMENT.
I SEE NO REASON.
WHY THE UNITED STATES WOULD WANT
TO CHANGE THIS TREATY IN ANY WAY
BECAUSE?
IN MY OWN TRAINED LAW I IT LOOKS
LIKE IF WE WANT TO DEPORT OF OF
NEWLY ARRIVED VIETNAMESE
CRIMINAL.
THE TREATY ALLOWS IT.
AND IT'S A VERY FAIR TREATY
BECAUSE VIGT NAM ESSENTIALLY
HAS THE LAST SAY.
ON WHETHER THEY'RE DEPORTED OR
NOT.
NOT TOO BAD PRETTY FAIR TREATY
SO HOPEFULLY THE PRESIDENT WILL
NOT.
CHANGE IT OR CANCEL IT.
I DO SUPPORT THIS.
STRONGLY THANK YOU.
THEY MUST VOEPEL MISTER
PATTERSON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
MEMBERS AYE STANNIS DRAWING
SUPPORT OF THIS A C. R. AND FOR
THOSE NEW MEMBERS --
MY OLDEST SON BJ'S VIETNAMESE WE
ADOPTED HIM --
THROUGH --
THE STRUGGLE OF SO MANY OTHERS
WHO HAVE COME FROM VIETNAM.
UP HE WAS ONE WHO CAME PRIOR TO
THE NINETEEN NINETY HE IS
PROTECTED AND SECURE BECAUSE OF
HIS CITIZENSHIP.
BUT AS A RESULT OF HIM BEING IN
OUR FAMILY WE BECAME PART OF THE
EXTENDED VIETNAMESE FAMILY.
THROUGHOUT CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
AND THE STATE.
AND I'M ASKING FOR A UNANIMOUS
AND FULL AND COMPLETE SUPPORT.
OF THIS REQUEST THAT SAYS THESE
PEOPLE FOUGHT FOR US THEY CAME
HERE THEY WERE UNDER GREAT
THREAT BY A COMMUNIST REGIME.
IF THEY GET SENT BACK BAY WILL
BE PERSECUTED.
AND ALTHOUGH MY SON IS SAFE.
MANY OF HIS FRIENDS WHO HAVE
GROWN UP TOGETHER.
AND WHO ARE NOW IN CIRCUMSTANCES
OF LIVING THEIR LIVES OUT.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF THEM ARE AT RISK.
AND SO I'M ASKING PLEASE IF WE
CAN BE UNANIMOUS MS --
I THINK --
AS GARB OF LEAGUE --
WHO WAS IN THE VIETNAM?
WAR SO RIGHTFULLY HAS POINTED
OUT.
THAT THAT THIS IS A TREATY OF
JUSTICE AND OF SAFETY.
AND THERE IS UTTERLY NO REASON
TO ABROGATED OR MASS WITH IT.
BECAUSE YOU MESS WITH THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE WE LOVE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED.
MISTER DAILY YOU MAY CLOSE.
I TRULY APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS OF SUCH A
DIVERSE GROUP OF OUR MEMBERS.
AND I WANT TO THANK A THE MEMBER
FROM SAN JOSE FOR BEING --
OUTSTANDING JOINT AUTHORED THIS
RESOLUTION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR ALL VOTE AND ASKED
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY.
THIS DAILY YOU WOULD LIKE --
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROLL.
THE MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS CORP OVER THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
OR CALL CULTURAL THEY'RE SIXTY
FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDED ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS AJ ARE AS SUCH WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS BETTER IS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
SIX KNOWS ZERO THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE MOVED TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS MONDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIRST.
IS THE MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
DAY HOLIDAY TUESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY SECOND FLOOR SESSION IS A
ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION.
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
ARE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE GREEN CARPET
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS.
MR BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO JOIN
IN THE MEMORY OF LARRY WINE
BURKE A SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSMAN
AND LEADER IN.
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REALLY --
THE NATION'S JEWISH COMMUNITY.
WEINBERG LEFT A LASTING IMPACT
ON HIS COMMUNITY IN SO MANY
ASPECTS OF HIS LIFE FROM HIS
MILITARY SERVICE HIS WORK AS A
HOUSING DEVELOPER AND
BUSINESSMAN.
AND HIS POLITICAL ACTIVISM HE
ENLISTED IN THE ARMY AT THE AGE
OF SEVENTEEN AND WAS HONORABLY
DISCHARGED AND AWARDED THE
PURPLE HEART IN NINETEEN FORTY
FOUR AFTER BEING WOUNDED IN
COMBAT.
HE MOVED TO LOS ANGELES THREE
YEARS LATER AFTER MEETING AND
MARRYING HIS WIFE BARBIE.
AND WOULD GO ON TO ATTEND UCLA.
WEINBERG THEN FOUNDED THE LAR
ONE COMPANY IN THE LATE NINETEEN
FORTIES AND TRANSFORMED A SMALL
ENTERPRISE IN TO ONE OF THE
LARGEST PRIVATELY OWNED HOUSING
COMPANIES.
IN THE UNITED STATES.
WEINBERG ALSO SERVED AS THE AS
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE HOUSING COMMISSION AND WAS
THE FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
OUTSIDE OF HIS WORK AS A HOUSING
DEVELOPER WEINBERG IS PERHAPS
BEST KNOWN FOR HELPING TO FOUND
THE PORTLAND TRAILBLAZERS BACK
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE THEY WON
AN NBA CHAMPIONSHIP TWO YEARS
LATE SEVEN IN ONE BURKE SERVED
THE AS THE TEAM PRESIDENT FOR
OVER A DECADE BEFORE SELLING THE
TEAM IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT LARRY
WEINBERG WAS ALSO POLITICALLY
ACTIVE AND A STAR SUPPORTER OF
ISRAEL AND SERVED AS PRESIDENT
OF THE AMERICAN ISRAEL PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE KNOWN AS A
PACK.
AND WAS A RECIPIENT OF THE
BROTHERHOOD AWARD OF THE
NATIONAL CONFERENCE OF
CHRISTIANS AND JEWS.
WEINBERG PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
FIRST AFTER BATTLING BONE MARROW
CANCER AND IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE BARBIE. FOR CHILDREN TWELVE
GRANDCHILDREN AND THIRTEEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE ALSO RECOGNIZE
AND THIS GERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF LARRY
WEINBERG WHO PASSED AWAY EARLIER
THIS MONTH.
JUST DAYS SHORT OF HIS NINETY
THIRD BIRTHDAY.
LARRY WEINBERG LIVED A
REMARKABLE LIFE THAT WAS DEFINED
BY LOVE A FAMILY AND SERVICE TO
COUNTRY AND COMMUNITY.
HE WAS A DECORATED WORLD WAR TWO
COMBAT VETERAN A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESSMAN IN NBA CHAMPION A
PROMINENT POLITICAL ACTIVISTS
AND A GIANT IN THE AMERICAN
JEWISH COMMUNITY AND THE
NATIONAL PRO ISRAEL MOVEMENT.
BORN IN BROOKLYN TO IMMIGRANT
PARENTS LARRY LISTED IN THE US
ARMY IN SEPTEMBER.
NINETEEN FORTY THREE HE FOUGHT
IN COMBAT IN EUROPE WHERE HE WAS
GRAVELY WOUNDED AFTER TRIGGERING
A LAND MINE.
AND BEEN BAYONETED BY GERMAN
SOLDIER.
AFTER MULTIPLE SURGERIES AND
MORE THAN A YEAR OF RECOVERY HE
LARRY WAS HONORABLY DISCHARGED
IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX HAVING
EARNED A PURPLE HEART.
THE COMBAT INFANTRY BADGE AND A
BRONZE STAR FOR MERITORIOUS
SERVICE.
SHORTLY AFTER RETURNING HOME
LARRY MET BARBIE WHO BECAME HIS
LOVING WIFE AND SOUL MATE FOR
THE NEXT SEVENTY ONE YEARS.
TOGETHER THEY WOULD RAISE FOR
CHILDREN TWELVE GRANDCHILDREN
AND THIRTEEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
LARRY BARBIE SOON MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY USE
LARRY'S DISABILITY BENEFITS TO
FOUND WHAT WOULD EVENTUALLY
BECOME THE LARGEST PRIVATELY
OWNED HOMEBUILDING* COMPANY
IN THE NATION. FOR LARRY
BUILDING HOMES WAS MORE THAN A
BUSINESS.
IT WAS A WAY TO PROMOTE THE
JEWISH IDEALS OF EQUALITY AND
INCLUSIVITY.
AT A TIME WHEN MANY MAJOR
HOMEBUILDERS PUBLICLY EMBRACED
REDLINING LARRY WAS A FIERCE
OPPONENT OF SEGREGATION AND AN
OUTSPOKEN ADVOCATE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS.
IN ADDITION A HOMEBUILDING AND
OTHER SUCCESSFUL VENTURES LARRY
HELP EXPAND THE REACH OF
PROFESSIONAL BASKETBALL.
HE SERVED AS PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE PORTLAND TRAILBLAZERS AND
IS CHAIRMAN OF THE NBA.
UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP THE BLAZERS
WON THE NBA CHAMPIONSHIP IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE
YOUNGEST TEAM IN MODERN HISTORY
TO BECOME WORLD CHAMPIONS.
WELL LARRY ENJOYED BASKETBALL
HIS TRUE PASSION WAS POLITICAL
ACTIVISM.
HE WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
A DELEGATE TO THREE DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CONVENTIONS AND A
CLOSE ADVISER TO DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE HUBERT
HUMPHREY.
CENTRAL TO LARRY'S POLITICAL
ACTIVISM WHERE HIS TIRELESS
EFFORTS TO STRENGTHEN THE BOND
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES IN THE
STATE OF ISRAEL.
A RELATIONSHIP THAT HE
UNDERSTOOD WAS VITAL TO THE
SECURITY OF BOTH NATIONS.
LARRY WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
HELPING TO GROW THE AMERICAN
ISRAEL PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
INTO A DIVERSE NATIONAL MOVEMENT
OF GRASSROOTS POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS IN ALL FIFTY STATES.
AS APEC CEO HOWARD CORE
EXPLAINED AT HIS FUNERAL LARRY
PROFOUNDLY SHAPED THE NATIONAL
PRO ISRAEL MOVEMENT.
AND HIS AFFECT AND IDEALS HAVE
INSPIRED GENERATIONS OF
AMERICANS TO BECOME ACTIVE IN
OUR POLITICAL PROCESS.
AT HIS FUNERAL LARRY'S GRANDSON
DANIELS ACCOUNTS HE CITED A
JEWISH ETHICAL TEACHING FROM
ATTACKS KNOWN AS PURE K. ABOUT.
YOU ARE NOT OBLIGATED TO
COMPLETE THE WORK.
BUT NEITHER ARE YOU FREE TO
DESIST FROM IT.
LARRY'S LIFE REFLECTED THAT
WISDOM.
AND HIS GREATEST LEGACY IS AN
EXTENDED FAMILY OF ACTIVISTS WHO
ARE COMMITTED TO CARRYING ON HIS
WORK.
INCLUDING A DAUGHTER AND
GRANDSON WHO ARE THEMSELVES
NATIONAL LEADERS IN THE PRO
ISRAEL COMMUNITY.
LARRY WEINBERG WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED.
BUT HIS MEMORY WILL BE A
BLESSING TO CALIFORNIA AMERICA
ISRAEL AND THE JEWISH PEOPLE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY IN HIS MEMORY.
THING WAS GABRIEL [inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
MY GOOD FRIEND BOB MELCHER.
HE PASSED AWAY QUIETLY ON
DECEMBER TWENTY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR.
BOB WAS A RESIDENT OF RIVERSIDE
WAS A LIFE LONG POLITICAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE ACTIVISTS.
AS WELL IS A DEDICATED TEACHER
COMMUNITY VOLUNTEER BROTHER AND
UNCLE.
BOB WAS BORN INTO MORE IN IOWA
AND MOVED TO REDLANDS CALIFORNIA
WITH HIS MOTHER AND YOUNGER
BROTHER IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX HE ATTENDED
UC RIVERSIDE.
EARNING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE.
HE WENT ON TO RECEIVE A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN POLITICAL SCIENCE FROM
UC BERKELEY.
AND A SECOND MASTER'S DEGREE IN
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION FROM CAL
STATE LONG BEACH.
BOB TADI COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THROUGHOUT THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
MOTIVATED STUDENTS TO ACHIEVE
THEIR DREAMS.
HE WAS A TWENTY YEAR MEMBER OF
RIVERSIDE'S UNIVERSALIST
UNITARIAN CHURCH WHERE HE SERVED
AS PRESIDENT MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES.
AND CO CHAIR OF THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE COMMITTEE.
I WAS ABLE TO VISIT BOB TOWARDS
THE END OF HIS LIFE.
AND IT WAS A PLEASURE TO SEE MY
FRIEND ONE LAST TIME.
BOB IS SURVIVED BY HIS BROTHER
STEPHEN SISTER IN LAW DEBORAH
HIS NIECE KATHLEEN AND HIS
NEPHEW JEREMY.
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA.
MR DAVID YOU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ALONG WITH OUR WEST
SIDE SAN FRANCISCO COLLEAGUE I
RISE TO ADJOURN.
IN THE MEMORY OF A WONDERFUL SAN
FRANCISCOCONSTITUENTS.
AYMAN MURPHY.
AYMAN EMIGRATED TO SAN FRANCISCO
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE FROM
IRELAND AND OVER THE YEARS
BECAME AN EMBODIMENT OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
BECAUSE OF HIS TENACITY HIS
STRONG WORK ETHIC HIS SUCCESS AS
A BUILDER AND REPRESENTING WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN PREPARATION MEETS
OPPORTUNITY.
A MAN WAS A FORCE OF NATURE.
KNOWN FOR HIS QUICK WIT.
HIS WRY SMILE.
HIS INCREDIBLE GENEROSITY AND
HUMILITY.
HE WILL BE FOREVER REMEMBERED BY
HIS FAMILY.
HIS MANY MANY FRIENDS HIS
LONGTIME PARTNER DENISE LAPOINT.
AND OUR BROADER COMMUNITY.
WHILE WE'RE ALL SADDENED BY HIS
PASSING HIS SPIRIT WILL CARRY ON
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO.
COMMUNITY AND IN THE MANY LIVES
THAT HE TOUCHED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES OF THE DEATHS TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL OUR
CRESTWOOD TURNING MEMORY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING HEARING OF FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR CHU MU'S MISTER COOLEY
SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL TUESDAY JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND.
AT ONE PM WE ARCHER